hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen Tamara
Tamra I blur my name together and people
think my name is Tamara today I am
watching the original 1968
Planet of the Apes I do know the ending
of this film already because I parodied
it parodied they did it parodied it I'm
sure it's been ruined too in other
places as well but you know nothing
really ruins an ending to a film than
acting it out I said what did I think of
the original Planet of the Apes
give me those predictions for the next
hour hashtag cameras never seen with a
gif it's very sensual I am not sure if
I'm very excited about this one but I'm
something let's do it
[Music]
oh my god the over acting I mean
Charlton has Heston his name
Charlton Carlton Charlton I don't know I
have a say his name but he is he's a lot
a lot going on also no background music
ever smells like ever there's a giant
gun fight scene at the end between like
the good guys and the bad guys and and
and there's no music it's just every
once in a while which is the gun noise
that they use I will say that though a
lot of the stuff doesn't hold up well
like the the prosthetics like the masks
that they wear look ridiculous every
time I saw the Apes I couldn't stop
thinking of that horse mask you know
that horse mask that horse mask but the
story is pretty damn cool I didn't
really I guess grasp or get why the
ending that he's on earth was such a big
deal and and I really like how they said
it I wish that the only female character
like starting off the mission just
didn't die immediately though I am glad
that she did pass away rest in peace
girlfriend because those guys were
really really really really really
really sex hungry they were gonna
repopulate the earth with three guys in
one girl what in the actual crap is that
what in the actual crap is that there's
that amazing quote oh girl
tell me though does man that Marvel of
the universe that glorious paradox who
sent me to the Stars still make war
against his brother keep his neighbor's
children starving and then he goes to
sleep for two thousand years I don't
know about in 2673 but in 2017 yeah son
you they do they land on earth again
which they don't know is earth but it's
immediately terrified they're sinking in
their spaceship the woman the one lady
that they brought along you know to pass
around with super aged and
that was not what I would expect someone
to look like after they've been dead in
like age like that doesn't it didn't
really look like what would have
happened to her but it looked cool I
guess I said holy shit old movies are
weird
one of the guys puts in a USA flag into
the rocks and Charlton Heston shirts
laughing at him
I guess cuz he's claiming the land for
them even though they're in this dire
situation it's a little it's choice but
the laugh is so weird he's like this
evil laugh and it hands up I don't want
to move the camera or the framing right
now so I'll just move down you get the
picture okay here we go it's what it
looks like ha ha ha oh it's just the
laughing girl from The Sorcerer's
Apprentice review ok anyways keep going
ha ha and there's like a two minute
scene of them just running down this
rock Mountain I don't imagine if that
was written in the script I think that
they were on location and they were like
well this is gonna be really difficult
to run down this rock mountain maybe
we'll just film it and add it in two
minutes I don't think there was music
behind it either
she really unsettling weird silent
running down on brock mountain so they
stumble upon a bunch of fit mute caveman
cuman's and a bunch of ratty brown wigs
like identical wigs for every human
actor blessed are the vegetarians so the
Apes show up looking big as ever none of
the humans can speak now you all know
this I don't need to refresh your
memories on this movie if he can't speak
right now so they think he's just
another Neanderthal human and he's
captured he makes a girlfriend out of
the prettiest Neanderthal because you
know of course when one beautiful woman
dies another enters your life that's the
same right
the two men he was with and exploring
one gets killed off in like this attack
of the Apes and then another is found
later he's trying to escape he stumbles
into this human museum that they have
which reminded me a lot of Wax Museum
which I think Paris Hilton was in so
that's the kind of quality movies that I
saw before I started this whole series
he's running around and he stumbles
across this one human figure in the
museum and it's the other friend
and that is horrifying and that is
creepy and I like that a lot
good for you so he's trying to escape
and everyone starts throwing water
balloons at him were they supposed to be
rocks why does everyone have water
balloons also none you know knocking it
sounds like a blast I would like to live
in that world sign me up
but just very odd wanted to point that
out and he's like it's a madhouse lot of
net usage it's like their only line is
like capturing someone is just throwing
out on him like a hundred times at least
and eight throws Annette in middle so
much net usage so the other guy wasn't
killed off I guess I lied he sees him
from across the way and he's like Landon
Landon speak so that they know I'm not
the only one and he turns around Landon
and they've cut his like brain out
because Lee ape does know that humans
were intelligent at one point and it's
just pretty good monkey kisses are
hilarious
okay another really weird moment is at
the very end Taylor and his beautiful
unwilling bride Nova I'm she's she's
willing I keep saying that but whatever
she just can't speak so we'll never know
they're about to leave and Taylor looks
at the doctor apron is like I would like
to kiss you good-bye doctor what her
fiance's right there and also your new
love interest is right like what they
got they they kiss and it's just so
weird and this is clearly an older movie
that would never like fly today just
different times man different times
different rhymes different crimes you
know I'm saying so the ending was
spoiled for me long ago like I said but
it did it seems so obvious to me I
wonder how many people that really like
zinged like really gat Nash just replied
is this a NASA mission or pornhub damn
what some hot takes that's Oh God that's
real yeah
Oh No you'll understand the hate for the
Tim Burton remake I've not seen the Tim
Burton remake nor did I know that there
was hate for it should I see it is that
something that I need to see in my
lifetime I imagine no you'll prefer
bearded Charlton Heston to clean-shaven
Charlton Heston am I saying his name rum
is it Charlton or is it Carlton
help but yes you will be saying to
yourself Jesus how did this get a G
rating how did this get a G rating
really G what the hell I've got it on my
screen here what in the actual hell is
this the prosthetics will make you
appreciate your working facial muscles
oh thank god oh yes yes I predict a lot
of Tamara staring at the sky and shaking
her fist in very Heston E ways notice
how I cut out the background music why
would you cut out the back I mean I just
I honestly I don't think I'll ever top
this performance critic what will she
find her destiny
[Music]
No
finally really did it
no but please just stay with me Nova
use your words Nova you will hate every
a PC from chimpanzee it's a gym oh thank
you so much for watching next week
hopefully I'm gonna be pairing up with
Malcolm ray to do a Tamra's never seen
episode on Dougs
favorite film Brazil if that doesn't
happen it'll be happening in the next
few weeks this morning I uploaded a hair
flip compilation video on my personal
channel so check that out you have any
interest in flips and I will see you all
next week it's a madhouse Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you